nueve meses de arduas negociaciones para
llegar finalmente a un acuerdo de
coalición el lunes por la noche los
líderes de los cuatro partidos
holandeses sonreían aliviados 13 261
días de negociaciones un nuevo récord
para los países bajos que ya había
experimentado 225 días sin gobierno en
el 2017 al inicio de las conversaciones
el líder de la unión cristiana gert jan
shaders se comprometió a no formar parte
de un cuarto gabinete de rute y la líder
del partido democrático 66 sigrid kaag
instó arte a dimitir después de meses de
estancamiento
finalmente cambiaron de opinión
como negociadores hemos llegado a un
acuerdo pero por supuesto todavía hay
que presentarlo a nuestros partidos y
debatirlo en la cámara de representantes
así que aún no está terminada creo que
tenemos un buen acuerdo pero al final se
trata de aplicarlo y ponerlo en práctica
hamburgo este acuerdo es una victoria
personal para mark rutte apodado el
primer ministro del teflón por su
capacidad para salir indemne de las
crisis más insolubles acaba de
recuperarse del escándalo de los
subsidios familiares por el que presentó
su dimisión el pasado mes de enero antes
de ser reelecto en marzo mark rutte
también es conocido por su arte del
compromiso construyendo coaliciones con
la izquierda la derecha e incluso la
extrema derecha el primer ministro ha
conseguido mantenerse en el poder
durante más de una década y con este
nuevo mandato se convertirá en uno de
los líderes más longevos de europa